[Musica]
Avete mai notato che in alcuni ambiti
della vita le persone faticano pensare
all'idea di evoluzione all'idea di
cambiamento all'idea di affrontare
qualcosa che non hanno mai conosciuto
la mia narrazione parte oggi da qui da
questa fatica dalla fatica di immaginare
che dobbiamo abbandonare vecchi
stereotipi e che forse è il momento di
pensare a qualcosa di nuovo
Quando ho conosciuto Nadia la prima
volta quando l'ho vista
il suo desiderio principale è stato di
condividere con me una confidenza ha
voluto dirmi che si sentiva libera
libera di vivere libera di essere se
stessa libera di pensare libera di
muoversi e le piaceva molto questa
sensazione perché era la prima volta
nella vita che si sentiva libera
ricordo di averla guardata intensamente
dritta negli occhi perché io non potevo
capire in quel momento non la potevo
capire non era il momento non c'era
nessuna possibilità per me di capirla
poi ho conosciuto drager
era un ragazzo serbo
età indefinita difficile dire quanti
anni avesse non era vecchio non era
giovane era sicuramente vissuto mi
raccontò che veniva da un paese nel
quale c'era la guerra e lui aveva
partecipato aveva combattuto in questa
guerra mi raccontò che aveva visto cose
che i documentari non ci raccontano mai
aveva fatto cose che era meglio che io
non sapessi mentre parlavo con lui
mi disse anche che era scappato da quel
paese perché non voleva più fare quelle
cose che non poteva dirmi e i draghi Era
molto arrabbiato era arrabbiato perché
voleva qualcuno che lo rispettasse
pensava che una persona come lui che era
scappata da un paese per Non commettere
più delle cose che non poteva dire il
rispetto andasse in qualche modo
accordato almeno quel rispetto che
doveva essere garantito a tutti gli
esseri umani e io faticavo a capire in
quel momento ancora non riuscivo a
capire
poi poi conobbi Maria Guadalupe
Maria Guadalupe mi colpì moltissimo
perché il suo sorriso era grande enorme
e i suoi occhi erano profondi e Maria
Guadalupe mi disse che era felice mi
disse che era felice perché i suoi figli
erano negli Stati Uniti perché ci
sarebbero rimasti perché avrebbero
studiato negli Stati Uniti sarebbero
stati liberi negli Stati Uniti e non
sarebbero mai più tornati nel loro paese
e lei era davvero molto felice e io
continuavo a non capire
Poi fu la volta di Donald
della storia di Donald è tutta un'altra
cosa
Donald Era diviso era lontano da me Ci
separava un tavolo un tavolo con una
montagna di carte sopra e lui lui voleva
parlare del Lago d'Iseo voleva che gli
raccontassi come era la primavera sul
lago d'Iseo voleva sentire gli odori
voleva vedere i colori voleva sapere che
gusto aveva il gelato di cui gli avevo
parlato nell'ultima lettera e mentre
faceva tutto questo cercava di toccare
con il suo piede il mio sotto il tavolo
Madonna non lo faceva perché avesse
bisogno di me lo faceva perché io in
quel momento ero l'unica essere umano
con cui lui aveva un contatto dopo 11
anni 11 anni di vuoto
in quel momento dopo dopo Nadia dopo
dragen dopo Maria Guadalupe dopo Mille
altri nomi iniziavo piano piano a capire
una comprensione lenta difficile e dire
anche dolorosa
quando conobbi Nadia si trovava in una
casa di reclusione in Italia e stava
scontando una pena a circa 20 anni per
aver tentato di uccidere l'uomo che
l'aveva privata della Libertà
l'aveva privata della libertà nella sua
vita precedente In quella vita che noi
normalmente consideriamo libera solo
perché non ha le sbarre alle finestre
Maria Guadalupe invece era in un carcere
a città demerico in uno dei peggiori
carceri dell'America centrale di quelli
comandati da in narcotrafficanti dove si
sopravvive solo se sia del denaro
altrimenti non ci sono speranze e Maria
Guadalupe stava scontando una pena otto
anni per aver accettato di trasferire
della droga da una parte all'altra del
paese perché con quella quel lavoro
avrebbe garantito ai suoi figli i soldi
per il viaggio per gli Stati Uniti e per
la vita futura
invece era in attesa di giudizio in una
casa circondariale in Italia Era
arrabbiatissimo
nel suo italiano stentato difficile da
comprendere però lasciava trasparire la
sofferenza e la devastazione che solo la
guerra Lascia nel cuore di un uomo
drager arrabbiato perché perché era
ignorato avrebbe voluto meno almeno
avere una risposta un no qualcuno che lo
incontrasse e Gli dicesse no qualcuno
che si rendesse conto che aveva
un'esigenza che quell'esigenza poteva
essere per esempio lavorare per mandare
due soldi a casa e mantenere i figli o
quell'esigenza di capire come
sopravvivere alla solitudine del carcere
e invece le risposte per lui non c'erano
mai i draghi incominciava a pensare che
probabilmente l'unico modo per farsi
notare era ricominciare ad utilizzare
quella violenza dalla quale era scappato
e che forse non voleva mai più
ricominciare ad utilizzare
Donald invece ve l'ho detto che era
tutta un'altra storia donna al di là nel
braccio della morte degli Stati Uniti in
particolare in Oklahoma in un carcere
tomba per uomini non morti che sono in
attesa di essere giustiziati che sono in
attesa che lo Stato li uccida
Donald avrebbe dovuto controllare con me
ogni documento ogni singolo foglio che
c'era su quel tavolo perché quelli erano
i fogli per chiedere la grazia erano gli
unici documenti che avevamo per poter
chiedere una grazia e lui non li
controllava lui voleva parlare con me
lui voleva vivere la vita attraverso le
mie parole e io veramente non potevo
capire non era una cosa che avrei
veramente potuto capire fino in fondo
un giorno mi disse
ci sarai quando mi uccideranno io quella
domanda non l'avrei voluta sentire mai
non avrei mai voluto dovergli rispondere
di no avrei voluto restare con lui
sempre per ogni singolo istante ma non
ero in grado non ero pronta non sono
nata per immaginare di poter vivere in
un mondo nel quale uno stato può
uccidere Legalmente un uomo e quindi
dissi di no E credo che ancora oggi
quella mia incapacità sia uno dei più
grandi tormenti con i quali devo fare i
conti
Andai però a trovarlo
qualche giorno prima qualche giorno
prima che lucidassero e in quel momento
in cui hai condannati a morte permesso
di scegliere l'ultimo pranzo mentre lo
Stato decide quale più l'ora più giusta
per ucciderti
dopo Nadia dopo
Donald dopo dragen
dopo Maria Guadalupe dopo moltissime
altre persone mi sono interrogata tante
volte sulla parola libertà su che cosa
vuol dire su che senso abbia avuto nella
mia vita quella parola
dopo che ho incontrato queste persone
e
se è possibile è possibile questa è una
domanda che mi chiedo sempre è possibile
sentirsi liberi in carcere e se è
possibile e non è un paradosso non vuole
Forse dire che qualcosa è andato storto
prima qualcosa in quella vita libera di
prima di quella vita libera di cui
parlavo senza sbarre alle finestre che
poi forse così libera non è per qualcuno
non è forse che qualcosa non ha
funzionato se ci si può sentire liberi
in carcere e poi ancora
essere invisibili non non contare nulla
non avere nessuna possibilità di
riscatto non essere niente per nessuno è
di questo che abbiamo bisogno noi fuori
e di questo abbiamo bisogno di questo
per sentirci più sicuri
ora che Donald non c'è più noi ci
sentiamo più sicuri il mondo è più
sicuro è un luogo nel quale possiamo
vivere più sicuri
Io non credo non riesco a convincermi di
questo e allora le domande continuano ad
accumularsi senza trovare risposta
e mi chiedo perché in un mondo nel quale
Siamo alla continua ricerca di
innovazione alla continua ricerca di
nuove risposte per i problemi quotidiani
alla continua ricerca di evoluzione
perché l'uomo ha ancora bisogno di una
giustizia che si è dimostrata
Fallimentare di una giustizia obsoleta e
vendicativa Perché l'uomo oggi ancora
questo bisogno e perché se siamo tutti
consapevoli che per salvare il pianeta
Oggi abbiamo bisogno di scelte decise
convinte che non possono più essere
procrastinate perché non riusciamo a
convincerci che per salvare l'umanità
abbiamo bisogno di abbandonare i vecchi
modelli di giustizia che hanno fatto
solo del male e abbiamo bisogno di
guardare avanti al futuro abbiamo
bisogno di guardare a modelli che
possano davvero prendere in carica la
sofferenza ma la sofferenza di tutti
certo resta un capitolo enorme aperto
quello delle vittime Forse vi starete
chiedendo se ci ho mai pensato
Certo che ci ho pensato le vittime sono
una parte integrante di questo discorso
ed è Forse per quello che fatichiamo ad
abbandonare i vecchi modelli perché
pensiamo che abbandonando quei modelli
vendicativi
faremo qualcosa di gravissimo nei
confronti delle vittime stiamo forse
pensando che abbandonando quei modelli
vendicativi
perderemo l'unica possibilità di punire
severamente che ha fatto del male
gratuito
non è così
non è così e non perché a dirlo sono i
soliti buonisti innamorati dell'idea di
riscatto nei confronti di Chiunque abbia
agito per il male non è così perché a
dirlo sono le ricerche le ricerche che
analizzano i risultati che la giustizia
riparativa dà nella vita degli uomini e
non è così perché sono le vittime stesse
che oggi sempre più cercano altrove Un
conforto alla loro sofferenza non nella
giustizia tradizionale non nella
giustizia vendicativa non lo è per
queste ragioni Quella non è una risposta
uccidere un uomo che ha ucciso non
riporta in vita la vittima non colma i
vuoti non sana le ferite non è di quello
che abbiamo bisogno
è la paura che ci fa credere di avere
quel bisogno specifico E allora il
pensiero torna alle persone di cui vi ho
parlato a draghi Anna Maria Guadalupe a
Nadia donade mi sono chiesta tante volte
tantissime volte quando Nadia uscirà dal
carcere Se nessuno lo avrà dato la
possibilità di capire che non ha bisogno
di un uomo per sentirsi accudita per
sopravvivere con quanti altri uomini
andrà a ricrearsi la prigione nel mondo
Libero
Con quanti altri e Maria Guadalupe
chi avrà ad aspettarla uscendo dal
carcere quegli stessi uomini che l'hanno
costretta a trasportare droga per avere
i soldi per salvare i propri figli
solo quello solo quello avrà niente di
più
e dragen dragen probabilmente tornerà a
pensare che la violenza è l'unica cosa
che ti toglie quel mantello di uomo
invisibile se sei violento riesci a
essere visibile qualcuno ti risponde
quello avremmo ottenuto con dragen
penso tante volte anche a Donald che non
c'è più e alla sua vittima che pure non
c'è più
però penso anche alle loro famiglie
Qualcuno avrà fatto qualcosa qualcuno si
sarà occupato di gestire la sofferenza
di quelle famiglie per quanto ne sono
nessuno nessun familiare è stato
avvicinato per affrontare il dolore che
ha subito e quindi abbiamo sbagliato
tutto
Questa è la domanda forse sì abbiamo
sbagliato tutto abbiamo probabilmente
pensato che occuparci del reato e della
possibilità che la persona che l'ha
commesso possa riconnetterlo di nuovo
possa essere una possa essere come viene
detto tecnicamente Recidivo sia più
importante che occuparsi del suo
benessere probabilmente occupandoci del
Benessere delle persone della
possibilità che dando loro delle
alternative possono comprendere che non
hanno bisogno di scegliere per il male
Forse allora sì qualcosa in più terremo
so che probabilmente ora vi chiederete
che fine fanno gli irriducibili in
questo discorso Chi sono gli
irriducibili sono quelle persone che mi
vien da dire per scelta non sempre
autonoma e libera hanno sostituito i
valori positivi del vivere sociale con
quelli negativi della devianza per loro
Forse è tutto più complicato questo
discorso andrebbe fatto in maniera un
po' diversa ma non ha tanta importanza
Perché le galere del mondo non sono
piene di irriducibili sono piene di
disperati E disperati nella nuova
giustizia nella giustizia riparativa
troverebbero un grandissimo aiuto
il castello di carta ormai è caduto ci
siamo trincerati all'interno di questo
castello per troppo tempo
incomprensibilmente per un lunghissimo
periodo quel castello a destra è caduto
ciò di cui abbiamo ora bisogno di essere
convinti del fatto che non ce ne serva
uno più resistente Ma che ci serva una
enorme capacità di guardare
all'evoluzione al cambiamento la
capacità di scegliere un percorso
diverso la capacità di capire che una
giustizia fallimentare non ha più
ragione di esistere abbiamo bisogno di
un nuovo tipo di Giustizia di una
giustizia che sappia prendere in mano la
sofferenza di tutti lo dobbiamo agli
autori
lo dobbiamo le vittime lo dobbiamo alla
collettività di cui tutti noi facciamo
parte in maniera unica e insostituibile
e se dovessimo riuscire a farlo se
questo cambiamento non ci spaventasse
troppo la fatica quella fatica che ci ha
seguito lungo tutta la narrazione che ho
condiviso con voi quella fatica Non
sarebbe stata vana perché avrebbe dato
luogo alla più nobile dell'evoluzione
quello che
vedete in questa slide sono i disegni
che Donald ha fatto per me perché non lo
dimenticassi
E questa quest'ultima immagine questo
suo disegno è la sua personale
rappresentazione del Lago d'Iseo non
l'ha mai visto ma l'ha immaginato così e
io Spero sinceramente che sia stata
l'ultima immagine Nella sua mente prima
di essere ucciso
[Applauso]